so if you've been watching this channel
for a little while you probably know
that I'm a big fan of cheese and I've
actually been starting to make my own us
here I figure if people like beer and
they brew their own beer and people like
wine and they brew their own wine why
can't I make my own cheese milk is one
of those things where it's kind of weird
it's a really weird by-product that we
eat like it's animal juice you ever
wondered how cheese is made this is how
it's made that white stuff and milk is
basically bits of fat proteins and
regular proteins they are suspended in a
liquid usually it's pasteurized meaning
unspoiled so there's no pathogens in it
and the next thing they do to it as they
homogenized it which is basically where
they take all those fat particles mix it
all up so it's evenly distributed
throughout the milk the thing is that
breaks down those fat molecules good for
milk but bad for cheese you want nice
robust fatty globs and your milk because
all those globs your base is going to
separate that from your liquid and those
globs you pack together and dry out and
that's how you make cheese so we wanted
to give you guys an update on what's
going on with studio four because it is
coming together really nicely so let me
take you around and show you what
they've done
Guillermo when the boys have been
working hard starting up here they've
brought in the sheet rock all the way in
and buttoned in this window there was a
gap in between where the original
skylight was and where the new skylights
fit that's gonna look really nice when
it's done as you can see these beams are
in pretty bad shape they need to be
sanded they're super dusty so the guys
are gonna go through they're gonna get a
rotary sander they're gonna come all the
way across here making this nice and
smooth and then they're gonna make it
pop with some beautiful color we got rid
of that old horrible air conditioner
that was about 30 years old and probably
had some cancerous materials in it it
really makes the height of the unit pop
out Guillermo has done a really good job
with this renovation so far I think he's
got about another two and a half weeks
to go it's a big day it's a big thing
for us I've dreamed about days with
insulation and air conditioning what I'm
going to do today I'm gonna take this
gallon of milk and I'm going to make
breathe now the process is basically the
same for other types of cheese today I
raw milk this milk has not been
pasteurized it has not been homogenized
it is straight-up raw milk from the cows
actually kind of hard to find costly
$17.50 but it tastes creamier and it's
more rich more robust and if I'm going
to sit around and spend hours making my
own cheese why not go the extra mile
right first things first
Carmichael you want to seal around milk
tastes like the fat stuck to the top of
it i shucked us all up he's stuck
getting butter tastes so good I grew up
having German milk with my grandparents
was like so close to the texture and the
taste mmm with my Chairman childhood
things you need to make cheese two
buckets of water our bowls regular water
for rinsing stuff off water with iodine
to keep sterile pot that I washed off
I'm really simply milking now you have
to bring the milk up to a specific
temperature in this case ninety degrees
Fahrenheit that temperature activates
the bacteria and the mold and promotes
growth all right we're going to leave
that let's go climb up our milk is at
the right temperature we are going to
put in the bacterial culture pure bags
Rula aromatic mesophyll you can buy this
stuff a bunch different places online
different cheeses use different
bacterias now put in the Penicillium
camembert cheese
this is a mold culture this is what's
going to grow white mold
stir it in nice and evenly distributed
through the milk let it now sit for 15
minutes there's a lot of new players in
the market for subscription digital
services and we've gotten a few offers
to pitch things so I'm going to take you
guys through that process of what's
required when you're pitching a new show
to a new client
every great idea can be boiled down to
two things a great name and a one
sentence description of everything you
need to know I came up with this idea
called country ops what does that mean
well it's a show about corridor teaming
up with the most experienced Special
Operations veterans in the world test
their field skills in an all for fun
redneck type game scenario this simple
description and title is what we would
call an elevator pitch it's called an
elevator pitch because you got to be
able to tell it to somebody that you
don't know in an elevator
they don't understand what you're
talking about you blew it kid after you
go through your description you want to
tell the reader a little bit more about
what they're getting themselves into on
my scenarios page I'll list out game
type scenarios that give a little bit
more context to what each episode would
be like demolition derbies ATV football
lawnmower racing what's not to love even
more important than what you write in a
pitch document is what you show the
viewer so you got to include things in
there that are simple and easily convey
your message next I move on to my format
page where I convey how the show is
presented to the audience now when
someone's going out and spending a bunch
of money on the show they want to make
sure that eyeballs end up on that
project they aren't able to go and to
talk to everybody and get to know
everybody so you got to show them
numbers so here for example I've shown
what our audience demographics are what
our geographical demographics are what
we're known for online and what kind of
connections we have that can help get
this series done at the end of the day
everything you do boils down to trust
and credibility and so our reach page
just helps emphasize that in fact we do
know what we're doing and we've done
this before lastly you want to hit them
with a little zinger that calls back to
the title of the show here I used our
phrase Cu in country this gives them a
memorable way on how they're gonna sell
your great idea when it's all said and
done don't be afraid and let your idea
fly into the world my papers
the cheese takes a long time I want to
make we air because that's a cheese
using fondue and I really like fondue
it's kind of expensive too we all just
look up how to make it takes about a
year so now we're going to put in the
rennet and rennet is an enzyme it's
going to cause the curd separate from
the way I'm going to take one of these
rennet pills basically just capsule to
solve it in some water now the thing is
you can't use tap water for that because
tap water has chlorine and chlorine will
kill your bacterial cultures it's the
same thing with salt salt ug has iodine
in it and at the end we're going to salt
the outside of the cheese to keep other
molds from growing
but you saw iodine it can also kill all
the bacteria sir your little shake this
is going to now start reacting with the
milk like for example you take your
blood you have blood cells but your
blood cells are suspended in your blood
plasma so we're effectively separating
the blood cells from the blood plasma
take those blood cells and pack them
into a little cylinder really turn into
cheese after just turning it over in the
mold for a couple hours and letting the
liquid drain out take the solidified
block of milk fat now I'll put salt on
the outside and put it in the fridge and
that's it that's the extent of work
that's all it takes to make cheese you
grab your milk mix you bacteria your
mold the rennet make it solidify and you
walk away more or less there's the whole
putting on the mold thing but it's
really not a big deal
like making cheese is really really easy
I was surprised at how easy it was it
just takes time yeah that's it I guess
web another cheese party in a couple
weeks